welcome my name is Gideon Gill I'm the
health and science editor at the Boston
Globe and I'm today's moderator today's
program is an hour long and it's a
collaboration of the forum at the
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
and the Boston Globe today we will take
a look at a pernicious epidemic drug
overdoses involving prescription pain
medication well describe the scope of
the problem and its causes the nature of
addiction the link between prescription
painkillers and heroin and steps to stem
the tide and address the crisis will
also hear today about a newly released
national poll conducted by the Boston
Globe and the Harvard th Chan School of
Public Health about attitudes towards
prescription painkiller abuse we will
take a few questions that have been
emailed to us for our panelists as well
you can also participate in a live chat
discussion that's happening on the forum
site right now today's panelists
starting from my immediate right are
Robert blendin professor of health
policy and political analysis at the
Harvard School of Public Health and the
Harvard Kennedy School to Bob's right as
Daniel Alford associate professor of
medicine assistant dean and director of
the safe and competent opioid
prescribing education program at Boston
University School of Medicine to his
right is Michael Botticelli Director of
National Drug Control Policy at the
White House and on my far right is
Monica Burrell Commissioner of the
Massachusetts Department of Public
Health
so to start Bob I wonder if you could
describe to our audience the poll and
its main findings at for the purposes of
our session we just pick four questions
that sort of circumscribe what would be
a serious discussion the first is do
people think this is a important problem
the reason why it's worth knowing that
is that though experts and public
officials may worry about something you
get a different response that most
people don't even think about it
the second question is do people
actually know people with this
experience and there you get a very
different reaction
there are the things I watch on
television every night I worry about but
it doesn't enter into my life but if it
does it changes how I behave the third
is what is it that people think is
reason for this to happen and because
it's hard to solve problems that people
don't believe it is the reason then the
last is and on this surface - there's
some things that people should know when
all the X our planet will do they
actually know that is that what they
actually talk about about this issue so
I'm going to do this very very quickly
so first the slide is the people think
this is an important problem and the
answer is it's actually a missus from
our national poll
as seen as great or greater than the
heroine threat in the United States so
if we had had a trend on this it
probably wouldn't have been anywhere
like this a decade ago and so this has
really gotten to be in the public mind
the second thing and this is the most
important thing next slide that I need
everybody to remember the rest is just
background that is in our poll 4 in 10
people said that they knew someone the
past five years who would abuse their
misuse prescription painkillers what you
go down very quickly is we just then ask
them did it have any effect on them and
look at the impact on family life work
life and health and the thing that is
staggering us is that if I knew somebody
one-in-five said somebody died from
painkiller abuse so this is not I saw it
on television or something like this
this is something that actually
permeates people's lives
the third thing slide will do this very
quickly
is what to do - too easy to get it or
buy it legally - easy to just keep your
pills around and it's prescribed too
often so but there's a division a lot of
people are not sure and the last slide
is on the knowledge side and this is
very important so if you were an expert
in this you expect that
every physician that prescribes payment
equation will have an extensive
discussion with their patients about
this issue and what we found is in
Massachusetts which is not the immediate
focus here the majority of patients
prescribed the painkiller did not
discuss it
with their physician the possibility
that there could be some sort of
addiction naturally it was four in ten
no one ever had talked to them or they
surely couldn't remember the last thing
and it's really very important there all
these policy proposals sweeping around
would say that we should require
insurers and others to pay for treatment
through insurance see it's perfectly
logical the people in our survey just
didn't know if there was any effective
treatment so this will be part of the
discussion today but remember I'm not
going to mandate and require people to
do things if I don't believe there's
anything that works that is sort of the
background for our discussion here today
thanks Bob
to better understand how addiction to
painkillers begins we're going to show a
brief segment from a documentary called
the opiate effect from Green River
Pictures and produced by the United
States Attorney's Office in the District
of Vermont the full video is free to
download for educators and the link to
the film's can be found on the forum
website my house is always the place
where nobody was there where I was okay
to have parties began with alcohol
drinking with friends I mean I
definitely went to parties and had fun
was partying wanting to fit in just like
any other kid
we want to think that there's a logical
process that's going on for young people
there is no logical process their
behavior is impulsive they don't think
logically through a process in the
beginning I got high it was fun nobody
ever plans on you know going farther
than that but you know one thing
obviously leads to another and they
think to themselves they didn't tell me
I was going to experience this they
didn't say it was going to feel good
they told me it was bad therefore
everything they've told me about
substances has to be called into
questions so then when they take a drug
that has some legitimate greater risk
they're less afraid to consume that
substance I already tried this one thing
what's the next gonna hurt once I found
opiates that was obviously last step you
will become consumed by it it will
control every part of your life there's
gonna come a day where you're not doing
it because it's fun anymore and if you
think that you can just walk away and
put it down you're kidding yourself
because you can't you will lose friends
you'll lose touch with family there's no
control and the scary part is you lose
control without realizing it's happening
people won't like the person you will
have become neither will dr. Alfred
you're a doctor who studies and teaches
about addiction and you treat patients
with chronic pain or have become
addicted to painkillers so what's going
on here how do you balance treating pain
with the dangers of opioid addiction
yeah so when I think back on how we got
to where we got it it's really not that
surprising a lot of for a lot of reasons
first of all chronic pain is incredibly
common it's probably one the most common
things that I see in primary care and
according to the Institute of Medicine
report back in 2011 approximately a
third of our population 100 million
people say yes they've had chronic pain
it doesn't mean that a hundred million
people need opioids or 100 million
people even need any medication but it's
just a chronic it's a common problem in
our society the other problem is that
we've approached chronic pain the same
as we approach acute pain and acute pain
is a symptom it's after you have an
injury and it's life-sustaining chronic
pain is a very different problem and
it's it's much more like a chronic
disease it's a multi-dimensional problem
and and if you're trying to treat a
multi-dimensional problem like acute
pain you're gonna run into problems so I
think there's been an over-reliance on
treating chronic pain with medications
and medications only and take it one
step further we've become very opiate
centric in our approach to treating
chronic pain and and part of that is you
know society believing that opioids are
somehow magical that they are the
treatment and and we now know that they
necessarily the treatment in fact we
know that patients with acute pain
almost 100% of the time will respond
- an opioid but chronic pain it's more
like 50% of people will get an adequate
response and so if you're assuming and
and part of the problem even with the
title of this talk you know painkiller
if people are expecting their pain to be
killed and gone
then they're gonna unrealistic
expectations and they're gonna put a lot
of pressure either on their provider to
increase the dose or they're gonna
escalate the dose themselves so again if
it's not working it's because they're
not on a high enough dose and so they
start to escalate the dose and so I
think we've learned a lot about the
complexities of chronic pain both how
calmer it is but also how complex it is
and how we've been mismanaged in chronic
pain by relying too heavily on
medications and opioids in particular so
I think we need to focus more on that
and the one last complication when I put
on my primary care hat is this is very
different than other things that I do in
primary care I use a risk-benefit
framework when I treat hypertension or
diabetes that is I prescribe a
medication I look for an objective
measure of benefit decrease in blood
pressure decrease in blood sugar and I
also look for objective measures in harm
maybe a blood tests maybe an increase in
and a blood test that tells me that
there kidney function is suffering from
this medication so I have to balance
that benefit and risk when you're
treating chronic pain with a medication
what's the benefit how do I measure pain
how do I measure a function how do I
measure quality of life and how much of
those changes in those domains is enough
to say it's working and then how do I
measure harm what does addiction look
like and I'll say that a lot of patients
who are coming to me with pain and
addiction don't see the addiction they
just focus on their pain issues and so
it's up to me to decipher this whole
thing in a 15-minute visit in a sterile
exam room when most of their life
happens outside that exam room so it's a
it's a complicated issue so I'm in a lot
of ways not surprised that we've run
into the problems we've run into and I
think we need to you know make a lot of
changes in terms of how people perceive
these medications but also how providers
use them thanks director Botticelli in
your role as director of the National
Drug Control Policy at the White House
can you describe the scope
of the problem nationally and how often
and why people addicted to painkillers
switch to heroin sure so first of all
I'd like to thank the Harvard School of
Public Health and the Boston Globe for
organizing this event there's a really
important dialogue that we need to
continue to refine our understanding of
the problem and really help us to refine
our policy solutions to this issue I
also want to acknowledge that two people
that are flanking me who I've known for
a very long time you couldn't ask for
more committed leaders and expert
leaders in Massachusetts and doing this
work I just want to start by saying we
know that there's not a silver bullet
solution to this problem it's a highly
complex problem it requires a
comprehensive strategy it really
requires all sectors of community to
come together to deal with this issue
I'd like to talk a little bit about the
findings and how that plays into kind of
the national scope and the national
issue you know clearly many people think
that the non-medical use of prescription
opioids is a problem and research from a
number of different federal agencies
support the fact that there are too many
of these drugs in being prescribed and
in circulation research estimates that
18 billion opioid pills were dispensed
in 2012 enough to give every American
over the age of 18 75 pain pills in 2013
the prescription opioid overdose rate
was nearly twice that of the heroin
overdose rate an analysis by the
substance abuse and mental health
services administration shows that four
out of five people who started using
heroin recently did so after using
prescription opioids non-medically so we
know that a significant portion of newer
initiatives started their opioid abuse
problem with prescription pain
medication however that transition from
non-medical use to heroin appears to be
limited to a small cohort of people
about this study showed four percent so
a relatively small portion are
transitioning and that transition
happens over a period of time so we
clearly know we have lots of
intervention opportunities to prevent
people from transitioning to heroin the
lesson here is that while heroin is a
growing concern we as policymakers must
continue to urgently address the
prescription opioid situation and
evidence-based solutions
in 2013 almost 44,000 Americans died of
a drug overdose and prescription opioids
accounted for more of these deaths than
any other class of drug and while
overdose deaths involving prescription
opioids lately have leveled off those
that resulted from heroin use are rising
among all drugs from 2012 to 2013 heroin
had the largest upsurge overall with a
39% increase startingly from 2006 to
2013 heroin deaths increased by an
incredible 295 percent so we're gonna
talk about these solutions later on but
it's really important for us to
understand some of the challenges and
myths that we have about overdose
prevention and some of our treatment as
some of the data showed we clearly have
work to do to educate the people that we
have important and effective treatments
here in 2013 alone approximately 1.9
million americans met the diagnostic
criteria for abuse or dependence on
prescription pain medication while
517,000 met criteria for heroin the rate
of babies born to exposed exposed to
opioids grew nearly fivefold from 2000
to 2012 and from 2009 to 2012 state
medicaid budgets paid for the
hospitalization cost for more than 80%
of these babies and really disturbingly
as of May 14th the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention found a hundred
and fifty-five patients with new cases
of HIV in one rural County in Indiana
this epidemic has been directly tied to
the opioid use nationwide data on this
are not available but a recent study in
Kentucky West Virginia Tennessee and
Virginia showed that 70 percent of newly
diagnosed hepatitis C patients under the
age of 30 with an identifiable risk
factor were people who injected drugs
from non urban areas Indiana actually
documented new HIV cases several years
ago well before the HIV outbreak but
this indicates new hepatitis C outbreaks
in people this age are a signal of
injection behavior in a community and
are a harbinger of increases in HIV
these statistics indicate we are truly
in the middle of a crisis and we don't
have time to wait to bring about change
coordinated efforts across public health
and public safety are essential the
National Drug Control strategy is a
comprehensive plan our office publishes
each year for Congress that explains how
the federal government is addressing
this issue with drug consumption and
non-medical prescription drug use this
strategy addresses issues of supply
reduction overdose prevention treatment
and infectious disease prevention in
2011 the Obama administration published
a prescription drug abuse prevention
plan to address the sharp rise in
non-medical prescription opioid use in
this country since 1999
we work closely with stakeholders and
professional associations in many states
to bring this issue to the attention of
governor's as well including governor
Baker as public health officials justice
officials in law enforcement officers
and others we have a pleco role to play
we have also worked with parents and
other loved ones and havoc see
organizations concerned with this
epidemic the plan the rx plan as we call
it outlined several action items which
we can talk about later but critically
education of patients and prescribers
increased drug monitoring prescription
drug monitoring proper medication and
disposal and law enforcement we also
continue to promote better access to
treatment particularly medication
assisted therapies and overdose
prevention efforts we have made a
significant strides in each of these
areas but clearly there is much more
work to be done I really look forward to
sharing policy solutions with the
remainder of the time today thank you
thank you very much commissioner burrell
we've heard about actually another
dismal picture of painkiller abuse
nationally and I wondered if you would
provide us with a Massachusetts
perspective sure thank you for the
opportunity to be here and the forum is
really such at the forefront of bringing
important topics to a national stage and
I want to thank the forum and the globe
for bringing this topic because there
was no other important public health
issue that we should be talking about
right now this is an epidemic as you're
hanging from the numbers and it's really
important we address this head-on so
just to give you a flavor of what's
happening in Massachusetts at a state
level so this is a problem as you've
heard from director Botticelli that's
affecting all of us at a national level
in the state of Massachusetts I'm gonna
also give you these some numbers and I
think the numbers are important because
has Professor blendin's polls showed
there's still a lot of misconception and
we don't you know we really need
information in order to move to action
all right because if we don't have the
same baseline understanding it's harder
to get to the point of action so in the
year 2013 there were 978 unintentional
opioid deaths in Massachusetts now what
do you make of that number just to give
you something to compare that we're used
to thinking about
there were 371 motor vehicle accident
deaths so two and a half times as many
documented unintentional opiate deaths
as there were a motor vehicle accident
deaths and behind those numbers right so
that's just the death that's the
ultimate indicator that we have but
behind that are at least 2,000 inpatient
hospital visits and over 4,500 emergency
department visits so as we look at these
numbers and you know they're really
daunting as you mentioned but you know
what can be done and I want to talk to
you just a little bit about some of the
things we're working on now so in
February governor Baker put together an
opioid working group and that is chaired
by our Executive Office and Health and
Human Services Secretary Secretary's and
I play an active role and I sit on that
so it's 16 members and what is unique
and helpful about this group is its
individuals from all sectors so the
points were raised earlier about this
being a community-wide effort so this
affects everyone in our communities and
we'll need again there is no silver
bullet so how can we find solutions
together to get us to the next step this
working group since February we've been
around the state and we've talked to
over 1,100 individuals in open community
meetings we've received multiple emails
and written Testament Testament
testimonies from people talking about
solutions when you sit and hear what
people talk about the vast array of
people it really gets to these poll
issues about how it's a vast problem
affecting all of us
so we have individuals who have
struggled with addiction come to speak
we have the parents of individuals who
are not only struggling with addiction
but who've lost their children to
addictions we have grandparents coming
we have siblings coming we have teachers
we have professors we have clinicians we
have advocates people in law enforcement
we have judges etc so it's really a wide
range of community members that are
coming together to talk about what the
issues are and what can be done and our
final report will be out in June but I
it is it is remarkable to me that with
these multiple different lenses people
are coming to the same conclusions and
those really talk about prevention at
the primary level
so before individuals are using how can
we better educate on what the effects of
opiate use are and then on secondary
prevention that when somebody's using
how can we help them after that and it
really importantly help their families
so the other thing that's really come up
is the need for more coordinated care so
oh you know the opiates are an issue
that to me is a chronic medical disease
when someone's suffering from opiate and
substance use disorder and the way that
we have this the stigma around it is
really palpable in these meetings that
we've been to so people are embarrassed
people have you know the way we've set
up our system to care for individuals
with this chronic disease is really
bucketed in different components of our
community that don't speak to each other
so when you are trying to get help there
are parents who come and say when I
found this out about my child that I
wouldn't imagine I didn't know where to
go now if you think about that and
compare that to something like a chronic
disease like diabetes everybody in this
room knows where to go if they need to
get their diabetes chapter they think
they have it and who should I talk to
but it's so different the way it's set
up so really this concept of different
treatments work for different
individuals but there's data driven
medication assisted treatment but not
enough people know about and not enough
people have access to or know how to get
it and not enough capacity in the system
so that's really an important thing
that's come up and also when somebody's
in recovery how do they get supported in
recovery
because just like other chronic diseases
like diabetes once someone with diabetes
is out of the intensive care unit we
still continue to follow them and help
them achieve success so I'm you know
really better coordination over the
system in this model of prevention
intervention treatment and recovery
thank you thank you very much Bob I
wonder if I can come back to you and ask
you about what the poll results are
suggest to you about public policy
usually you say 7 out of 10 wasn't
something rather our taking this is
where people have to understand this
problem more so the first thing is Mapei
tient what should my physician have
talked to me about before I regulate
what they should be doing the second
thing is I have a loved one with this
problem what's available for that the
narcan which is the more used term we're
gonna debate whether or not something
should be available from a pharmacy or
first responders I'm actually sure the
people that we interviewed had no clue
what we were asking it's just whether or
not I'm afraid of drugs so I want it
more regulated or not so the question I
really have for the panel is what should
somebody expect their physicians that do
before we regulate them what would you
actually say to a family member could be
effective and lastly what is the narcan
debate really about from a person's
point of view so so to follow up on that
let me ask director Botticelli to one of
the one of the clear messages in this
poll is that one in five people so one
of five people took prescription
painkillers in the last two years and
and that's both in nationally and in
Massachusetts and especially in
Massachusetts many were not told of the
risk of addiction by their physician
moreover roughly half of the poll
respondents as we've heard from Bob were
you know exceeding roughly half of the
poll respondents said that the
painkillers were prescribed either too
often or in excessive doses so I guess
what I want to ask you is do you first
of all do you agree that painkillers are
prescribed too freely for chronic pain
and what can be done to better educate
prescribers and patients sure so these
data kind of substantiate what we've
known a long time that when you look at
the consequence of the opioid epidemic
they've been tracked with the increases
in pain prescribing and you know we've
been promoting a balanced strategy that
we want people with pain appropriately
treated but it's very very clear that
they're being overprescribed and first
and foremost our plan and what we
continue to call for is some level of
mandatory prescriber education that
physicians get little to no training on
just addiction in general but
particularly on pain prescribing and
there was a General Accounting Office
study that estimated veterinarians
actually get more training in pain
prescribing than physicians do so
clearly you know and as both a person in
recovery I have my own experience with
physicians who are trying to do the
right thing but we're often tried to
give me pain medication went which is
kind of antithetical to my own recovery
so so we clearly need to do a better job
at making sure that we're giving these
medications to people who need them that
we're monitoring this dr. alfred has
been running programs FDA has been
supporting REMS education Massachusetts
is actually one of very few states
nationally that actually require some
minimal level of continuing medical
education for physicians so given the
epidemic we don't think it's
unreasonable to ask physicians to
prescribe it the second piece that I
think that you talked about is really
true is you know to continue to and
that's why forums like this become
critically important so that people are
aware of the issues involving these I
think you know part of what's been tied
to the prescription opioid epidemic is
the feeling that they are safe to use
because they're prescribed by a
physician so you know again there's lots
of injury of
interventions and educational
opportunities that we can implement but
first and foremost I think really
looking at from a prevention standpoint
not starting people down this path by
prescribing these medications for people
who might be at risk or people who are
developing problems dr. Alfred can you
describe for us a couple of these
programs that dr. Pollock telling either
doc director Botticelli mentioned which
is the the safe and competent opioid
prescribing an education of pain program
that you run as well as this FDA program
that for drug made makers regarding
physician and patient education sure
sure
so the safe and company opiate
prescribing education program that I run
is part of a larger national effort that
was started a couple years ago actually
had been going on much earlier than that
but it was kind of implemented a couple
years ago and it was put forth by the
FDA
and what they they did is they put
together a REMS program which stands for
risk evaluation and mitigation strategy
and and they do that for a lot of
medications that have risk and whether
it's you know the medication is going to
be hitting the market soon or it's
already out there and they found a risk
that they didn't know about they asked
the manufacturer of that medication to
create a program to mitigate that risk
and usually it's patient education and
prescriber education this is unique in
that the FDA said to a group of
manufacturers actually 19 of them we
want you and these are these are
companies that make extended release
long-acting opioids they said we want
you all to pool your money together and
fund accredited providers of Education
like Boston University to train
prescribers and the FDA said not only do
I want you to pull your money together
but the content the curriculum needs to
be based on our blueprint so the FDA
created the blueprint for the content
and then asked the companies to fund
accredited providers to take that
content and entrain and so scope of pain
is just one of those programs and it's
really geared towards again training
physicians now there's not a mandate to
people prescribers are not mandated to
take it outside of Massachusetts and a
few other states
but the manufacturers of these
medications are mandated to fund the
training and we've we've had some really
good success with it and we have for the
most case fill our courses within days
if not within weeks of promoting it and
I think there's a real desire to learn
how to do this better because I think
physicians are are afraid and there was
a survey that was done in central
Massachusetts where they surveyed ten
community practices and asked them
what's the number one reason preventing
you from scribing opioids in ninety
percent said I'm worried about addiction
so it's a fear there's a fear of
addiction and maybe it's you know you
know how do you operationalize that fear
so that you can use these medication
safely which driving people to come see
us and so our program is really geared
towards how do you assess pain and
function and quality of life those
complex outcomes that we're all looking
for but also how do you assess misuse
risk how do I know for any given patient
what is their risk of Meuse using this
opiate prescription and we know that a
prior history of addiction family
history of addiction legal history being
younger than 45 even having a nicotine
dependence put you at higher risk for
misusing an opiate prescription it
doesn't mean I'm not going to prescribe
it but it means that I'm gonna have a
conversation with you about your risk
and monitor you a little more closely
with the tools that I have to look for
misuse because oftentimes when people
start misusing them they don't even
recognize it themselves and so really
what I'm looking for is measuring
looking at their urine drug test to make
sure they're taking what I'm prescribing
and not taking something else I'm we're
doing pill counts to make sure they're
taking it exactly as prescribed and
we're checking the state prescription
drug monitoring program which is a
database that the pharmacist the
pharmacies when they dispense a
medication a controlled substance like
opioids enter it so I can look up for
any given patient to see what
medications they've had dispensed from
the pharmacy are they just coming for me
are they doctor shopping going to other
providers and so forth so these are all
the tools that I use and this is what we
train and I think probably one of the
most important things that these
training programs cover is how to have a
conversation with patients because you
can imagine you go to medical school to
take care of people and you assume
there's a trusting relationship
and and back and forth and when you've
got somebody who's addicted to a
substance
you know they lie to themselves they lie
to their families and they lie to
providers and so it becomes a very
complicated conversation to to talk to
patients about the need to come off
these medications and get into treatment
and so we train people how to do that
Commissioner I wanted to ask you if you
could just talk about the requirement in
Massachusetts for doctors to go through
training and did it surprise you given
that Massachusetts is one of the states
that requires that training to see that
so many patients who were prescribed
painkillers said that they had not been
advised by their physician wasn't a
great outcome measure so I think it's
very important that physicians are
required to do training here now
remember that the training is around
proper prescribing of pain medications
in which you know a component of that is
the issue around addiction and you know
it's it is three hours over two years so
I think it's definitely a starting point
and I think it's definitely a necessary
tool in our toolkit and I think all
prescribers should really be promoted to
do that at the minimum so am I surprised
no because most people don't get the
majority of their information from their
doctor's office so in order for us to
get the message out we really need to be
touching in different components of our
community as well well I have you can
you expect a little bit about naloxone
or it's also known as narcan can you
explain what that is what it does and
describe the efforts here in
Massachusetts sure I'd be happy to have
it distributed through first responders
yes so um when when somebody takes
opiates at a lower dose the opioids work
as a pain reliever it's not better than
a painkiller
so as a pain as a pain reliever as a
pain reliever when you take it at higher
doses it can have the effect of
suppressing breathing so when someone is
in that situation where their breathing
is suppressed there's a medication
called naloxone many people know it as
narcan which can be administered by
really anybody and the way it's
administered it used to be that you had
to have a needle and inject it and the
latest form you put on this nasal
attachment and just like you would take
Afrin or something nasally you can admit
it as minister to someone who's
unconscious and what it does is it
reverses the effects for a short period
of time of the opiate so that the person
within minutes if they're unconscious
from an opiate use wakes up so this can
be life-saving and a really important
tool in our toolkit when we're thinking
about opiate and especially around the
emergent situation where someone has
taken too much opiates and their
breathing is suppressed so in
Massachusetts starting in 2007 we began
having pilots where initially we focused
on injection drug users who were
actively using and getting it out into
the community so they were able to see
how this was how they can use this
within the community then we went to
what's called bystanders and that's
really family members or friends who
could be near somebody who they think is
at risk of overdosing so they can
administer the naloxone and in addition
to providing the basic training that
comes with a naloxone we also did and we
also do education on what opiate
overdose looks like how to do rescue
breathing's the importance of calling
9-1-1 because as I mentioned the effects
lasts for a short amount of time but
they still need to then get medical
attention and then from that starting in
2010 we then expanded further to first
responders so police and fire who
oftentimes get to an event right
somebody calls 911 when they get to an
event and they can tell that it's an
overdose but they have no tools and of
course as you can imagine if someone's
not breathing you have to quickly
reverse this
so we have 23 different high risk
communities around Massachusetts who are
now using naloxone as a tool we've given
out since the beginning of this program
over 35,000 different kits and have
documented over 5,000 reversals so it's
really a powerful tool in the toolkit
and hopefully can be expanded beyond
what it is now not only in Massachusetts
but across the country so on that point
director Botticelli what what is being
done nationally with naloxone into
available so quite honestly building on
the work that happened here in
Massachusetts our office has been
promoting the widespread use of naloxone
particularly among first responders and
we've been working with the National
Governors Association and others we now
have over 26 states that have passed
some level of legislation to allow a
broader group of people to distribute
naloxone we worked with our partners at
the Department of Justice and at the
substance abuse and mental health
services administration and have issued
overdose toolkits on how to do this I
actually just attended a roundtable of
fire chiefs from around the Metro Boston
area who are very interested in
following on a number of fire chiefs to
administer naloxone this is again is an
incredibly important tool that we've
seen I think first responders play a
critical role because in many parts of
the country we know that the issues
around prescription drug and heroin and
then particularly hard hit in rural and
suburban areas and so particularly first
responders can play a critical role here
in making sure that we're reversing
overdoses in parts of the country where
we don't have other infrastructure where
we don't see treatment programs where we
don't have other outreach programs so
they play a critical role and you know
and I have to say you know we've seen
tremendous and surprising uptake by law
enforcement and other first responders
around the country they have really
stepped to the table and very
dramatically is in a very compelling
ways to administer naloxone the second
piece and I'll say this that we have
seen a tremendous amount of partnership
between law enforcement and public
health that not only do they want to
reduce overdoses but they're looking at
ways to partner with the treatment
community
and the recovery community to use those
as intervention opportunities to get
people into care so they understand the
significance of not only of saving
someone's life but using it as an
intervention opportunity and follow-up
to get someone into care you see do you
find reluctance on the part of law
enforcement in some places to engage
with this in that some view this as
encouraging open illegal opioid use
remarkably little I have to say
remarkably little and and I think for a
couple reasons one that many of these
law enforcement have had as your data
show personal experience with people in
their community who have died and I
think that that has fundamentally kind
of changed their attitude and see
themselves as part of the solution
I you know I also think building on the
work that happened here we have
incredible champions in the law
enforcement community who've been able
to talk about this and and I think
people understand fundamentally this is
not about enabling that this is about
saving someone's life and that we have a
responsibility just like we do if
someone has a heart attack to save
someone's life regardless of whether or
not they choose to be complying with
treatment you know we don't we don't
predicate saving someone's life for
other diseases based on their
willingness to be complying with
treatment we saved their lives because
their lives are worth saving and so I
think we've seen a tremendous amount of
support for for the these kinds of
efforts thank you so as we've heard the
the poll found that many people the
majority people don't don't know about
effective treatment for pain reliever
addiction and so a director Botticelli
if you could talk about what so what are
the facts about treatment so so first of
all III think it says a couple things
that that one is we really have to
promote the other side of the equation
and that we really have to hold up
people in recovery and really share
their voices because part of what we
want to do is make sure that people
understand there is hope and life and
joy on the other side of addiction that
stigma still plays a huge role the data
are surprising
the sense of that we do if there is a
bright spot here we do have highly
effective medications for the use of
opioid disorders that have been shown to
be a more effective than any other
treatment that we have here these
however are tremendously underutilized
medications they are underutilized in
our treatment system in our criminal
justice system and we have an
opportunity to really build on the
uptake of these medications along with
other behavioral therapies and that's
been a big part of our federal effort to
increase funding and to really require
our federal grantees to use these highly
effective medications as part of their
treatment regimen dr. Alfred to do
anything yeah yeah and I think
historically we've held treatment for
addiction to a different standard than
treatment of everything else that I do
in primary care that is if I put
somebody on a treatment and they get
better I say the treatments working and
if I take the treatment away and their
problem becomes you know reoccurs it
gets bad I say that treatment really
worked
but with addiction treatment you you put
somebody on treatment they get better
you take the treatment away and it stops
working and people say the treatment
didn't work but really the treatment did
work is just you took it away and so I
think people need to understand people
need to understand that you know
addiction treatment needs to be long
term and whether it includes medications
or not you know again wearing my primary
care hat I know that there are lots of
different medications I use for treating
hypertension and diabetes and I wouldn't
say that you know one is absolutely the
better than another it's individualized
it depends on the person and there are
other comorbidities so I'd like to keep
an open mind where the diction treatment
to I mean there are some people who do
very well with with medication someone
who do very well without medication and
so I think it's important for our
community to understand that that it's
you know there are lots of different
treatments out there and some work for
some people and not for others do
we've had some mention of the
prescription drug monitoring program and
I wondered commissioner burrell can you
talk about what that program does and
how it works here in Massachusetts sure
I'd be happy to so I spoke earlier about
the importance of data and having an
understanding before we go to action and
another component of having data is this
prescription monitoring system and again
you know I'm just thinking as folks
we're talking about this you know the
really the underlying current here is
stigma and segregation to me so the
segregation of components and care and
it's really this undercurrent of stigma
and how we as a society think about this
chronic disease versus any other one
that we treat so just to put that out
there so as we're talking about the
prescription monitoring system so in
Massachusetts we have a prescription
monitoring system in place that we've
had for several years and several months
ago I used it as a clinician so what it
is is that when you have a patient
sitting in front of you there's a
database that you can look so John Smith
comes in wants a medication I can then
on my computer screen look up and see
which opiates he has received in the
last 12 months so this has become a very
powerful tool in the doctor's office to
be able to see what other prescriptions
were given the way that the system works
is that it's throughout Massachusetts
and any patient was receiving any
prescription with an address in
Massachusetts so even if they get the
prescription out of state is in the
system so it's this huge database of
information it also is connected to the
pharmacy so the pharmacies have the same
information and is meant to be again
another tool to make an informed
decision around whether or not the
person sitting in front of you is
struggling with addiction or needs pain
meds or where else they're getting their
prescriptions so we have had there at
this point all physicians are required
to be on the system and connected to the
system and 79% of physicians are and
it's a requirement related to their
license so eventually we'll have a
hundred percent and our next step is to
make it more user friendly because the
end user experience is still inhibiting
individuals from using it more actively
in their clinical flow so it's really
become a good way for individuals to get
notification and for pharmacies so that
they can yet then use that piece of
to inform what they're doing speaking of
data dude do you know what percentage of
physicians are actively using the
database yes so that's a good question
so in the way the current prescription
monitoring system is set up it's
probably about twenty to thirty percent
the problem with that number though is
that we don't have the denominator
because not every physician who signed
up it's mandatory to signed up is
actually prescribing opiates so we hope
we're going to enhance our prescription
monitoring system in the next few months
and hope to have a more sophisticated
way to accurately report that part of
having individuals use it more though is
to have it be more user friendly which
is one of our primary things that we're
working on now director do you want to
talk about nationally what's happening
sure these programs so I think this
underscores where the commissioner is
talking about so a big part of our
strategy has been to increase the
prescription drug monitoring programs
and its utility so in 2006 I think we
had 20 states that had prescription drug
monitoring programs and as of today we
have 49 states in the District of
Columbia Missouri as the last holdout
and I won't talk about why but so part
of what we're doing is not just that we
have these programs operational but to
the commissioners point we have been
working at the federal level to make
sure that these programs can talk across
state lines so interstate operability
has been a big goal we've also been
working on ways and pilot programs to
increase the utility and usability of
these program so we've been working with
Office of National Coordinator on how do
you link these programs to electronic
medical records and health information
exchanges so that physicians and
prescribers don't have to kind of log
off one system and log on another that's
a normal part of the record you know let
me just say too that we've seen where
these programs have been implemented
where we have robust prescription
monitoring programs and where they're
used we've seen some tremendous success
in the reduction of people who are going
from physician to physician and actually
Florida which was kind of the outlier
state to begin with had significant
reductions in prescription drug related
overdose deaths when
these programs and other things were
implemented so again it's one part of a
large strategy the last thing I'll say
is I think we still have opportunities
to look at how do we train physicians
that when they're identifying someone
who might be going from physician to
physician to not just cut people off in
these medications and again use those as
an intervention opportunity and a
referral for treatment so we have some
questions from our online audience Lisa
yes thanks Gideon and we have an active
chat going on online so I encourage
everyone to go on that as well here's
one related to prescription monitoring
many states are encouraging the use of
electronic prescribing of controlled
substances EPS C to prevent fraud and
theft related to prescription drugs
early reports indicate that it is having
a positive impact but adoption of EPCs
varies by state and is very low overall
what is the panel's view of the strategy
shouldn't we be focusing on this as well
as the prescription monitoring programs
actually that has when we that was one
of the strategies they identified in the
plan we think there is significant
opportunity here to increase prescribing
as it relates to safe and kind of not
fraudulent use of these we've been
working with the Drug Enforcement
Administration in terms of looking at
kind of regulations as it relates to
enhanced e-prescribing so you know again
we do we do see opportunity there around
increasingly prescribing as a good
strategy here Commissioner did you want
to know I agree with dr. Bhattacharya
that it would be incredibly useful the
you know the issues around
interoperability and EHR we're also
looking into those in Massachusetts to
see how we can move forward great things
I know we just have a little time left
I'll take a few more I've been learning
a bit about abuse to turn technologies
for painkillers to help stem the tide of
addiction for example making painkillers
that have features that prevent the
drugs from being snorted or chewed isn't
the FDA involved in developing new reg
relations around this and do you think
these new technologies hold promise yeah
so I think we've learned some lessons
about extended-release long-acting
opioids where you know they're they're
essentially short-acting opioids but
they're packaged in a way that when you
ingest them the way you're supposed to
do that is swallow them there's a slow
release so you get twelve hours worth of
relief as opposed to four hours the
problem being that you have to put a lot
of molecule in that tablet in order to
get that 12 hours of relief and if if
you crush it and snort it you get a lot
of short-acting and that becomes very
rewarding and very addicting and so as a
result of that a lot of the
manufacturers of these medications are
creating formulations that are much
harder to crush or if you do crush them
they become like a gel so you can't
sniff it or you can't inject it and so
these are great these are great
technologies but my teaching to you know
providers is to to never you know really
let your guard down to always assume
that someone's going to figure out how
to how to misuse it if because you know
fundamentally the medication has to be
metabolized within the body in order to
get the active drug so I'm sure there's
a chemist out there somewhere who could
figure out how to bypass any of these
but I think it's all good and I think
we've seen that as a formulation becomes
more abuse deterrent or resistant people
are much less likely to misuse it and go
for some of the easier ones so and the
FDA's role is really creating criteria
where as the manufacturers of these
medications in order for them to prove
that it's abuse resistant because as you
can imagine they're putting these
medications out there and saying it's
abuse resistant but yet it hasn't really
been out there so you don't really know
so there are criteria as to what needs
to be satisfied in order to call it an
abuse deserve great well we've also had
some questions about alternative drugs
that aren't opioids so let's take one of
those there are drug options for
controlling pain that don't involve
opioids but they cost more than current
therapies I believe what can we do to
incentivize researchers and
pharmaceutical companies to develop
these alternative
occations they make them more affordable
maybe I'll start so part of the work of
the NIH and NIDA has really been to amp
up research to really focus on non
narcotic analgesic pain therapy so
clearly we know you know as Nora Volkov
talks about that we actually really
don't have a great kind of armamentarium
of good pay manage and particularly for
chronic pain and that's a work that we
have to do so there's clearly an
opportunity to do that but one of the
things and again this is where the all
sectors come together one of the things
that we've heard from physicians that we
have to continue to focus on is often
they don't want to prescribe narcotic
analgesics but often insurers won't pay
for things like acupuncture and massage
therapy and physical therapy so how do
we incentivize insurers and others for
physicians who and patients who don't
want to take narcotic analgesics but
need some pain relief so I think clearly
there's opportunities as we go forward
to think about how we incentivize not
just the research but the practice
around kind of pain management yeah
there's one other thing I'd like to add
is when I when I'm managing a
complicated disease or a patient with
with a complicated form of diabetes or
hypertension
there's specialists that I can call upon
to get a consultation the field of pain
medicine is fairly new and there aren't
enough pain specialists out there who I
can rely on to get consultation so not
only do I not have these other treatment
modalities available to my patients that
I can then refer them to but I also
don't have specialists readily available
either to get help so it really is
reliant on the primary care population
primary care providers who who haven't
been adequately trained yet you there
are a lot of other questions so again
please go online but I want to give time
for the final statements thank you so
yeah we need to wrap up so unfortunately
we could talk for hours about this so I
want to ask each of you to identify or
recommend a policy takeaway that the one
thing that you think you
really need to take away from this
discussion Bob so surprisingly it's a
little bit different relates to director
Botticelli so the the critical issue for
in 10 people know someone who is in the
situation of abusing and misusing it the
critical thing I believe as many of them
would try to intervene more if they were
convinced there what really was a way
there could be a recovery community this
issue of hope at the end of the line so
I'm all for making sure physicians give
you this but a lot of people know
somebody in their life and the question
is could they push them direct them
across their family because there really
is hope at the end of the line where
this is something that's going to drag
on
so my policy recommendation is we need
more of you on the Hope side because
this is really important about how
people respond the people they know
thank you for saying that you know we
see that as an important important
function of our office you know I I'm
the first person to hold the position
you come from public health background
I've been in my recovery myself for 25
years so and we use our office to talk
about that we actually just hosted the
first recovery event at the White House
last year there are people in this
audience who have had lifelong efforts
to put a face and a voice to people with
recovery because it really is clear we
we need to show hope on the other side
because why would someone seek care if
they didn't see a life on the other side
dr. Alfred yeah so I just want to alert
the policymakers when they're thinking
about you know creating fixes for this
problem that easy fixes oftentimes have
unintended consequences and so though
though I think they're all
well-intentioned that is you know there
are states that have put limits on the
milligrams of opioids that you can
prescribe or the duration and that
absolutely will decrease the amount of
opioids that are being prescribed but it
also puts the people who have chronic
pain who might be benefiting from these
medications at risk as well and they
also don't have a very unified voice and
so I
just say that any kind of easy fix
should really be thought about in terms
of is it too blunt of an instrument that
I'm going to adversely affect people who
might be benefiting but there's no
question that the pendulum around opioid
prescribing has swung way too far to
becoming you know we're 2 o P eccentric
but I don't want to swing it all the way
back where where people are being under
treated for their pain thanks and
commissioner so I think that really this
is going to take a broad audience of us
and a multi-sector approach to look at
this multi prank problem with solutions
and prevention intervention treatment
and recovery but really focusing at this
intersection that we spoken a lot about
today of medical care and public health
care where we're looking at some
specific things we can expand that we
know work because the evidence is there
so education expanded education the
prescription monitoring system narcan
use and more availability of medication
assisted treatment and supporting people
in recovery I think for all of you I
have a request which is around we need
everybody in our community to think
about this as an integrated problem and
the issue of stigma we really have to
overcome that in order to come to a
positive solution stick together so
thank you for being here today because I
think that's a really important part
director did you have any other was
there anything else you were going to
add or okay good so thank you all for
joining us for this event thank you very
much to our wonderful panel for your
incisive comets
those of you who are online I encourage
you to continue the conversation on the
forum website which is forum HS ph org
thank you very much and have a good rest
of the afternoon